kaboulon en aller simple documentaire
réalisé par Olivier Bauer à 7000 km de
chez eux et sans vraiment pouvoir
envisager un retour l'histoire touchante
vous venez de le voir d'anciens
interprètes afghan accueillis en France
voilà maintenant en 6 ans dans la
préfecture de l'Aisne avec leurs
familles cela ont pu être filtré face à
la menace des talibans mais qu'elle sort
à ton plus généralement réservé aussi
villafghans qui ont combattu aux côtés
de l'armée française durant la guerre
menée dans leur pays nous allons en
débattre maintenant avec nos invités
présents sur ce plateau de débat doc
avec vous pour commencer Abdoul le
razakadi bienvenue on vient de vous voir
dans ce film vous êtes donc l'un des 24
interprètes réfugiés allant depuis
maintenant 2016 et suivi bien sûr dans
ce documentaire vous êtes par ailleurs
le président de l'Association des
Anciens auxiliaires de l'armée française
combien d'adhérents comptent votre
association aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il y
a à peu près 8 membres qu'ils ont adhéré
à notre association qui se trouve à Metz
dans différentes villes de France allant
et Strasbourg et à Lyon et parmi eux
certains ne se trouvent en dehors de
France il y a certains d'autres
interprètes ou PCL ou personnels civils
de recrutement local qui se trouve en
Afghanistan en Turquie en Iran dans les
pays limitrophes de l'Afghanistan on va
y revenir bien sûr avec vous dans un
instant Magalie Guadalupe miranda est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
avocate au barreau de des Hauts-de-Seine
experte en droit d'asile et ont droit de
la famille et particulièrement attentive
bien sûr au sort des réfugiés afghan on
va bien sûr aussi en parler avec vous
sur ce plateau avec Lucie du gros Toulon
bienvenue à vous vous êtes journaliste
vous avez collaboré avec LCI le
quotidien Lacroix et le média TV et vous
avez eu l'occasion d'enquêter justement
sur le sort réservé aux civiles afghan
ayant aidé les forces français en
Afghanistan on va juste rappeler après
ce film ce qui a été l'engagement
l'armée française en Afghanistan il
s'étale entre 2001 et 2014 il y avait
jusqu'à 4000 militaires français en
Afghanistan en 2010 c'était alors la
quatrième contribution à la coalition
internationale un retrait progressif de
nos troupes a été décidée par François
Hollande alors chef de l'État à partir
de 2012
89 militaires français avaient trouvé la
mort jusqu'en 2012 et 470 blessés ont
été dénombrés entre 2010 et 2012 cette
guerre a été la plus meurtrière sur
place pour les troupes françaises nous
nous sommes retirés d'Afghanistan en
2014 autrement dit sept ans avant la fin
de cette guerre et la conquête du
pouvoir par les talibans c'était bien
sûr en août
2021 simplement pour revenir ce que vous
avez dit dans ce documentaire
pour que ceux qui nous regardent
comprennent bien quel était votre
mission sur place et dans cette période
que je viens d'évoquer de présence des
militaires français dans votre pays en
Afghanistan quand avez-vous été recruté
et quand est-ce que vous avez aidé nos
armées et dans quelles conditions sur
place lorsque l'armée française a
intervenu sur le solde d'Afghanistan de
en 2001 l'armée française avait embauché
800 PCL personnel civil recrutement
local
parmi 800 il avait 400 interprètes qui
ont avaient aidé l'armée française
j'étais un de ces interprètes qui
avaient travaillé toujours en tant qu'en
interprète avec l'armée française avec
la compagnie d'infanterie avec la
compagnie d'escadron et avec le dpst
donc à part de faisait l'interprétariat
et la traduction et je faisais la
patrouille aussi côte à côte de l'armée
française dans différents province et
différentes districts de l'Afghanistan
et vous étiez très opérationnel dans ce
documentaire vous dites bah oui
l'interprète c'était le premier qui
rentrait dans un village lorsqu'il
fallait opération militaire dans
certains villages
c'était toujours l'interprète qui était
à la tête de l'équipe de la patrouille
de l'armée française c'était toujours
nous qui seront Sané concernent les
insurgés et leurs sympathisants donc
c'était toujours l'interprète qui était
la première cible pour les talibans et
leur sympathisants alors vous dites j'ai
parfois utilisé on m'a parfois équipé
d'un FAMAS c'est un fusil mitrailleur
français est-ce que vous avez eu à
l'utiliser ce fusil qu'on vous confiait
parfois dans ses missions sur le terrain
bien sûr de temps en temps quand il
avait une opération particulière
militaire dans le district de ce revis
par exemple dans la province de capita
c'était toujours le chef de l'équipe ou
le lieutenant ou le colonel de l'armée
française que nous fournissait un FAMAS
de se défendre parce que la situation de
sécurité était très précaire dans le ou
en rentrant pour la patrouille et pour
fouiller la maison on était obligé de
garder un FAMAS et de se défendre alors
concernant ces fameux pcrl il faut
s'habituer à ce terme un personnel civil
de recrutement local c'est le terme qui
est retenu pour l'administration
française notamment
quelle est la situation de ce et celle
que nous avons vu dans ce reportage à
Londres cette préfecture de l'Aisne qui
qui a donc accueilli 24
anciens interprètes sur place et leur
famille ça représente environ 170
personnes je crois ou en sont-ils s'ils
ont après leur arrivée en France
aujourd'hui quel est leur condition et
notamment leurs conditions
administratives alors sans doute que
Monsieur Adil pourra répondre mieux que
moi mais ils sont venus avec un visa
long séjour puisque c'était dans le
cadre des différentes vagues de
relocalisation donc ce visa long séjour
leur a permis ensuite d'avoir une carte
de résident donc un titre de séjour de
10 ans si vous voulez
et en l'état ils sont en situation
régulière en France je sais que certains
ont fait des demandes de naturalisation
ils en parlent notamment dans le
documentaire apparemment ces demandes
sont en attente
j'ai pas connaissance de refus mais en
tout cas c'est en attente de traitement
on verra ce que ça donne est en précisé
que ayant servi avec l'armée française
je vois difficilement comment on
pourrait ne pas leur donner une une
nationalité française qui a ce stade pas
de bizarre octroyé pour ceux qui
n'avaient pas de visa et qui sont donc
venus par leur propre moyen il y en a
notamment par exemple j'en pense à un
client à Strasbourg qui était dans cette
situation là celui-là a dû passer par la
procédure d'asile une fois arrivée
illégalement sur les territoires
français il a déposé une demande d'asile
et ça demande d'asile a été acceptée
donc il a le statut de réfugiés ce qui
lui donne aussi la carte de résident de
10 ans et pour ce qui la nature
c'est une éventualité si les personnes
ne souhaitent effectivement ils peuvent
bien sûr faire leur demande étant
préciser que ayant serv avec l'armée
française il n'y a pas la le critère de
durée ce qu'on appelle d'habitude la
durée de stage pour la nationalité
française donc même très rapidement ils
peuvent déposer leur demande de
naturalisation étant pour l'immense
majorité d'anciens interprètes ils ont
un niveau de français qui est quand même
excellent et évidemment bien sûr et puis
les traductions sont quand même assez
impressionnants de naturalisation une
demande de visage depuis un an j'ai fait
une demande de naturalisation mais
malheureusement j'ai pas encore reçu une
réponse favorable vis-à-vis ma demande
c'est toujours vague bon alors il y a
autre chose de vague dans ce dossier
sont les chiffres sont les critères de
sélection qui ont prévalus pour ses
excuses
qui nous avait aidés sur place et des
forces françaises sur place alors il y a
un rapport d'information qui a été
réalisé par la Commission de la Défense
nationale ici à l'Assemblée nationale
par d'une part Jean-Charles l'arseneur
qui est député Renaissance et Alexis
Corbière député la France insoumise ce
rapport a été communiqué en avril 2021
autrement dit quelques mois avant
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans d'août
2021 et alors il nous donnait ce chiffre
107 afghans avaient travaillé sur place
pour l'armée française dont 538
autrement dit la moitié d'interprète
comme vous et avec
317 personnes expiles avec leurs
familles en avril
2021 vous corroborez ces chiffres y
a-t-il encore un doute sur ces chiffres
on a semble-t-il déjà eu du mal à se
mettre d'accord sur le nombre de
personnes que ça que ça touchait avec ce
rapport là on a pu essayer d'avoir des
chiffres un peu plus précis on a essayé
de faire devoir par vague avant ce
rapport là on a pu identifier plusieurs
vagues la première vague entre 2012 et
2014 qui a permis d'exfiltrer les
premiers interprètes et les premières
personnes qui travaillaient dans les
bases militaires qui avaient autour de
CAG en Afghanistan ensuite il y a une
seconde vanne en vague en 2015 en
réponse à des manifestations devant les
ambassades de certains interprètes qui
voyaient leurs camarades déjà arrivés en
France et qui se demandaient pourquoi
eux ne pouvaient pas avoir accès à au
visa et ensuite on a eu grâce à la
mobilisation de certains avocats un
revirement dans le droit
administratif vous pourrez en parler
sûrement mieux que moi c'est à dire que
ils ont les interprètes et les personnes
qui ont travaillé dans ces bazars ont eu
droit à la protection fonctionnelle ce
qui a permis de rapatrier plus de monde
et là on a eu ensuite une réponse de de
l'administration française qui a essayé
d'entraver un petit peu les
rapatriements et donc on arrive à ce
chiffre là à peu près de rapatriement à
la fin on voit du documentaire on voit
317 et en fait c'est 317 là c'est les
227 avant la chute de Kaboul plus les 90
qu'il y a eu qui ont été rapatriés après
la chute de Kaboul grâce aux missions
qu'on a appelé les missions à Pagan un
deux et trois avec des ponts aériens qui
ont eu lieu et donc 90
en août 2021 on va y revenir dans
l'urgence absolue le chaos absolu et
alors que les troupes françaises ne sont
plus sur place ce sont les Britanniques
et les et les Américains qui contrôlent
notamment ce fameux aéroport suivi vous
pouvez se faire les les excusations au
final donc trois vagues nous dites-vous
dont l'une vous a bénéficié
517 en avril 2021 sur 1067 personnes
autrement dit déjà à cette époque ce
n'était qu'un tiers de ces civils
afgangs qui avait été
filtré c'est très peu finalement c'est
très peu après il y a des chiffres il y
a des gens qui ont été relocalisés
c'est-à-dire que il y avait une
procédure pour expulser pour avoir des
visas pour que ils arrivent en France
mais il y a eu c'est aussi eu des
procédures pour qu'il soit relocalisés
en Afghanistan dans des provinces où
c'était un peu plus sûr pour eux après
la chute de Kaboul évidemment rien
n'était vraiment plus vraiment sûr mais
avant il y a eu des procédures où ils
avaient des aides pour être relocaliser
autre part et ensuite il y a aussi vous
en parliez des gens qui ont quitté le
territoire afghan sans procédure légale
et donc là on n'a pas vraiment de
chiffres puisque ils ne sont pas
comptabilisés alors est-ce qu'il faut
pas distinguer ce qui a pu être fait
évidemment dans des conditions on va
dire à peu près normal
jusqu'à 2018 et puis effectivement ces
évacuations dans l'urgence de 2021
est-ce que tout ce qui s'est fait avant
l'arrivée des talibans au pouvoir et le
chaos d'août 2021 s'est fait dans des
relations vous qualifieriez de bonnes de
correct ou alors ce n'est pas le cas
d'après moi en fait la procédure
d'évacuation a commencé depuis 2013 au
début il y avait 74 familles qui ont été
choisi par le ministère des Affaires
étrangères et puis la deuxième vague
aussi ça a commencé en 2016 et certains
d'autres à nos collègues ont réussi
d'obtenir le visa dans les pieds les
métros comme Pakistan et errant et tout
ça mais il y a certains d'autres qui ont
rejoint
je connais un de mon ami qui est venu en
France et les classer en procédure de
blanc donc la procédure a commencé comme
ça mais la procédure c'était toujours
vague et on ne comprend pas beaucoup de
sélectionner bien sûr il avait trois
critères qui a qui ont été choisis par
le ministère des Affaires étrangères
première critère c'est la capacité
d'intégration deuxième critère c'était
la qualité service rendu à l'armée
française et
troisième critère c'était
la période de service rendu à l'armée
française pourtant nos collègues
pouvaient remplir ces critères mais
malheureusement ils n'ont pas pu
bénéficier de cette procédure de
relocalisation en 2016 lorsque
finalement vous parvenez à arriver en
France est-ce que vous pressentiez que
les talibans allaient reprendre le
pouvoir dans les années qui allaient
suivre ou est-ce qu'on en était pas
encore tout à fait là bien sûr le jour
que l'armée c'est retirer de
l'Afghanistan nous avons perdu notre
espoir parce que nous avons fait à
plusieurs reprises une demande de visa
mais notre demande visa a été rejetée
par l'ambassade de France qui se trouve
à Kaboul depuis cette date nous nous
sentions désespérés et complètement déçu
et nous pensions qu'un jour les talibans
allez arriver au pouvoir et donc c'est
pour ça que nous avons décidé de faire
plusieurs
fois la manifestation pour qu'on puisse
réussir d'obtenir un visa et de revenir
en France alors ça ce sont des
opérations qui ont eu lieu souvent sous
l'égide de à la fois du ministère des
Affaires étrangères vous l'avez dit de
l'ambassade et aussi d'une certaine
demande de l'armée française ces
fameuses sélections est-ce qu'on peut
distinguer ces phases c'est à dire tout
ce qui était fait avant l'arrivée des
talibans et puis cette phase
d'étalibans et après alors c'est une
vraie distinction à faire d'un point de
vue on va dire organisme tutelle c'est
que la première vague de localisation
2012-2013 elle avait été fait plutôt
sous l'égide du ministère des armées
parce que c'était la Task Force
Lafayette qui était en charge donc de
déterminer les personnes qui qui
pouvaient rentrer donc les 74 PCR et
leur famille qui ont pu venir dans la
première vague ensuite pour la deuxième
et troisième vague c'était plutôt le
ministère des Affaires étrangères
et pour apagant je ne saurais vous dire
qui était vraiment en charge de la
sélection j'ai plutôt l'impression que
c'était le ministère des Affaires des
étrangères mais en toute hypothèse le
ministère des armées garde toujours on
va dire un regard essentiel parce que
c'est le ministère qui a le service des
personnes qui sait que telle personne a
bien travaillé pour pour la France et
l'état de son service c'est également le
ministère des armées qui est sans doute
le mieux renseigné via la Direction du
renseignement militaire sur la réalité
des menaces et la cellule de crise a été
vraiment débordée et je pense que c'est
même un euphémisme de dire ça elle a été
débordée par le nombre d'appels le
nombre de personnes qui qui ont eu qui
ont besoin d'une évacuation en urgence
d'une protection et donc malheureusement
elle a été un petit peu sous
dimensionnée et à ce jour elle ne répond
toujours pas donc en l'état d'un point
de vue strictement légal le ministère
des armées et l'autorité vers laquelle
on va se tourner pour la notion de la
protection fonctionnelle puisque c'est
l'employeur de nos pcrl et le ministère
de l'Intérieur est également celui vers
lequel on va se tourner puisque c'est
celui qui règle les demandes de visa
c'est très clair en fait la plus d'un an
et un plus d'un an après la chute de
Kaboul on voit que les les ambassades
des pays limitrophes sont encore
complètement débordés l'ambassade de
Kaboul a fermé en septembre 2021 donc
peu après la chute de Kaboul et les du
coup les pcrl qui veulent partir doivent
se rendre d'abord dans un pays
limitrophes donc c'est le Pakistan ou
l'Iran et ensuite faire une demande de
visa depuis l'ambassade du pays sauf que
d'abord ils doivent payer un visa qui
coûte très cher le visa pakistanais là
j'ai un exemple je suis en contact avec
un pcrl qui a payé 1000 dollars son visa
pakistanais il a laissé donc sa famille
derrière lui ses 5 enfants et sa femme
parce qu'il ne peut pas payer les visas
pour tout le monde il s'est rendu là-bas
après avoir reçu un appel du ministère
des Affaires des étrangères qui lui a
dit 10 ans après c'est bon rendez-vous à
l'ambassade d'Islamabad il s'y est rendu
il a attendu 22 25 jours sauf que le
visa pakistanais périme au bout d'un
moment il n'avait toujours pas de
rendez-vous à l'ambassade alors qu'il
avait fait la demande et c'est pas je
pense de la mauvaise volonté de la part
de l'ambassade d'Islamabad c'est juste
qui croule sous des dossiers il donne un
numéro attendez vous allez avoir un
rendez-vous et au final les dossiers
s'empilent sans pile et il est toujours
là à attendre et c'est seulement avec un
peu de pression politique et en essayant
d'avoir accès directement à
l'ambassadeur qu'on arrive à faire
remonter le dossier au dessus de la pile
alors c'est toujours bon de regarder ce
qu'on fait les autres bien entendu les
Américains bien entendu qui sont restés
eux jusqu'au bout sur en Afghanistan
jusqu'en 2021 les Britanniques qui ont
rapatriés je crois quelques 7000 en tout
cas qui est engagé quelques 7 nuits
d'auxiliaires sur place puis aussi les
Italiens qui étaient côté
particulièrement attentif qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire de leur gestion du rap
patrimoine c'est fameuses auxiliaires à
comparer à la gestion qui a été celle de
la France les Britanniques ont comme
vous l'avez dit embauché 7000 pcrl ils
en ont pas trié environ 1300 et le reste
ils ont essayé de les aider à leur
relocalisation et les Américains ont
beaucoup plus rapatriés mais en termes
d'intégration et d'aide à l'intégration
en Amérique enfin aux États-Unis là
c'était un peu moins probant après je
pense que vous avez un rapport qui me
semble que alors oui il y a une étude
là-dessus venant de chercheurs de
l'Université de York alors Sarah de Jong
et je vais écorcher son nom je suis
désolé dis moi ça rentre petit 10 voilà
qui justement ont fait un rapport qui
qui mettait en avant la capacité des
différents états de la coalition à
assurer le retour ou la mise en sécurité
des personnels civils qui avaient
travaillé avec eux et c'est vrai que
malheureusement la France en tout cas
dans l'anticipation est plutôt mal
classée bien classé dans la réaction au
moment dapagan mais avant
malheureusement clairement il y a eu un
petit peu une politique de l'autruche
c'est à dire pour l'instant tout va bien
pour l'instant tout va bien puis on se
réveille le 15 août 2021 en disant bah
zut il y a des talibans et à ce moment
là il faut évacuer des gens et c'est la
fameuse opération à Pagan voilà tout à
fait
et la difficulté c'est que j'ai par
exemple en tête une personne qui était
magazine et pour pour l'armée française
qui avait fait un contentieux qui avait
une décision en sa faveur de la Cour
administrative d'appel de Nantes depuis
mai 2021 qui disait vous avez un mois
pour ramener ce monsieur et ben au
moment de l'ouverture de la mission à
Pagan il était toujours un Afghanistan
et parce que c'était tellement
désorganisé on n'a pas pu le ramener
pendant la mission impatant il est
revenu après
via une espèce d'expiltration au
compte-goutte mais si les décisions de
justice avaient été avaient été traitée
en temps voulu avait été respecté par
l'État si les demandes de visa les
demandes de protection avaient été
traitées en temps voulu on ne serait pas
dans cette situation avec encore
quasiment 200 personnes sans compter les
familles qui se retrouvent encore dans
une situation d'extrême vulnérabilité en
Afghanistan en Iran en Pakistan ou
ailleurs justement on va regarder un
extrait du du documentaire il s'agit de
d'une femme qui parle dans ce
documentaire et qui craint justement
pour la vie de ses proches restez sur
place
quand l'étalon ils sont venus à Capoue
c'est la France qui nous a sauvé
c'était dangereux pour mon mari pour mes
enfants et pour moi parce que tout le
monde a dit que vous êtes des espions de
la France
et il disait que ton mari aussi il
travaille avec les étrangers avec les
Français et toi aussi avec les Français
et à cause de ça que nous sommes obligés
de venir en France pour sauver notre vie
parce que c'est ça l'enjeu c'est de
protéger aussi ce qui reste bien sûr
vous même vous avez encore de la famille
sur place est-ce qu'il se sentent menacé
bien sûr surtout depuis la sortie des
forces de temps de l'Afghanistan la
famille de l'ancien combattant en fait
qui se trouve bloqué en Afghanistan et
ce sont de menacé par les talibans et
par l'État islamique parce que pour les
talibans il n'y a pas de critères
vous êtes des traîtres nous sommes
considérés comme des très très espions
donc de fait de notre collaboration
depuis longtemps avec l'armée française
dans différents provinces et nos sommets
identifiées donc c'est pour ça qu'en
fait nos familles qui se trouvent en
Afghanistan et sont tous menacés par les
talibans et donc en l'occurrence vous
avez un frère encore sur place j'ai un
frère oui j'ai un frère et ma mère aussi
qui se trouve actuellement dans la
province de qu'est-ce que votre frère
lui-même avait participé à aux actions
menées du côté de l'armée française au
même titre que où il était moins
impliqué
j'ai deux frères j'avais un frère qui
était toujours interpré de côté de
l'armée française on Afghanistan j'ai un
autre affaire aussi qui était polyvalent
qui travaillait avec
UCL de l'armée française à l'aéroport de
Kaboul donc il y a un frère qui a réussi
d'obtenir son visa de venir en France en
2016 et l'autre il est encore en
Afghanistan et il a tenté à plusieurs
reprises de faire une demande visa
auprès de l'ambassade de France
atterrant et au Pakistan mais
malheureusement il n'avait pas toujours
une réponse favorable vis-à-vis sa
demande et pourtant
j'ai envoyé une lettre à Monsieur Macron
en tant que représente en tant que de
représentant des interprètes de l'armée
française mais malheureusement j'ai reçu
aucune réponse ni de la part de Monsieur
Macron ni de la part de ministère des
Affaires étrangères
pour ceux qui restent le chiffre de 200
ancien auxiliaire on peut les appeler
comme ça alors oui c'est une cote m'a
taillée parce qu'on a beaucoup de mal à
savoir finalement beaucoup ont perdu
espoir essaie de se retourner vers
d'autres vers d'autres étapes parfois
certains avaient travaillé pour
plusieurs forces de la coalition donc
ils essayent un petit peu partout et
puis on en a quand même beaucoup en ce
moment je trouve qu'ils sont en Iran
étant précisé que les agents sont
extrêmement maltraités en Iran donc on
ne peut pas considérer que ils aient un
endroit un point de chute sécurisé et
toute la difficulté mais c'est même déjà
simplement déposé un visa madame le
disait c'est la croix et la bannière
pour déposer un visa on maintenant on
est obligé de faire des contentieux
devant le tribunal administratif de
Nantes pour avoir un rendez-vous pour
faire la demande de visa donc
malheureusement il sert on a un
collectif d'avocats qui ont fait notre
maximum on le fait pro bono quand il y a
pas de rémunération qui est possible à
la juridictionnelle mais on ne peut pas
traiter tous les dossiers et parmi les
personnes qui nous avaient contacté on
avait environ 250 personnes
au moment de la chute de Kaboul donc
quand on enlève ceux qui potentiellement
ont été expuliteraient grâce aux
missions à Pagan on tombe sur à peu près
200 personnes de 100 familles de pcrl
effectivement ce qu'on parle des PCL qui
sont encore sur place comme vous le
disiez encore les familles il y a
j'étais rentré en contact avec un
monsieur qui a réussi à venir en France
finalement en l'été 2022 et qui en fait
deux mois après qu'il soit arrivé ses
frères ont été arrêtés par les talibans
et lui disait si mes frères ne sont pas
libérés je vais retourner en Afghanistan
me rendre et qu'il libère mes frères
parce que ses frères n'ont pas travaillé
ils sont en études sont des jeunes
hommes ils ont ils ont pas travaillé
pour l'armée française et ils baptise de
de ce travail qui avait ce monsieur et
lui vit en France avec sa femme et ses
enfants mais le reste de sa famille est
encore là-bas est-ce que vous diriez
vous au regard des exemples cités tout à
l'heure les Britanniques les États-Unis
que notre politique a été plutôt du cas
par cas concernant ces fameuses
auxiliaires qui ont travaillé pour
l'armée française à différencier d'une
politique claire précise telle qu'on
puis la mettre en place les Britanniques
et les Américains après leur départ et
pendant qu'ils étaient sur place pour
livrer cette guerre plus que du cas par
cas je pense que ça a été très obscur et
qu'il y avait des situations où comme
les émotions c'était pas très clair sur
les conditions d'accès au visa il y
avait on parlait tout à l'heure de de
bien parler français etc beaucoup des
interprètes pour l'armée française
n'étaient pas francophones mais
anglophone et traduisait en anglais et
il y a pendant la vague de
2015 où il y a eu 103 visas qui ont été
acceptés mais 149 qui ont été refusés et
sur ces 149 là 90% étaient anglophones
ce qui veut dire on voit quand même
qu'il y a certains critères qui
n'étaient pas dit directement mais qui
en fait sont sous-jacent et qui amène à
avoir des refus qui sont pas vraiment
motivés les avocats ont essayé de
comprendre pourquoi il y avait vous le
disiez le les capacités d'intégration
etc et il y avait aussi il y a eu un peu
une instrumentalisation du de
l'argument sécurité est-ce que c'est
facile d'enquêter sur le sujet qui nous
préoccupe aujourd'hui lorsqu'on est
journaliste est-ce que vous avez des
réponses auprès de l'armée du ministère
des Affaires étrangères pourquoi pas de
certains députés ici à l'Assemblée
nationale sur ce sujet ou est-ce que
c'est difficile d'enquêter sur ce sujet
j'ai enquêté depuis la France pas comme
par exemple Quentin Muller et Brice
Glower qui se sont rendus en Afghanistan
et qui a écrit un très bon un très bon
livre sur le sujet moi j'ai enquêté
depuis la France et je pensais que le
plus difficile serait de rentrer en
contact avec des PCR qui sont encore en
Afghanistan en fait le plus difficile
c'était d'avoir des réponses du
ministère des armées qui ont répondu
simplement un mail en concluant que les
aucun pcrl n'était décédé en raison de
ses fonctions et en fait c'est pas
vraiment le cas vous souhaitez ajouter
quelque chose oui alors bah déjà c'est
pas le cas et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant de voir que ce discours
officiel entre guillemets que l'on
retrouve notamment dans une note de
l'ambassade de France qui date de juin
2021 on nous explique que aucun pcrl est
mort dans le cadre de ses missions mais
à moins d'un mois après il y avait Abdul
Bassir qui était cuisinier de l'armée
française qui a été exécutée donc déjà
c'est intéressant comme comme
chronologie par ailleurs en août le
président avait donné l'instruction de
les évacue au plus vite que c'était la
priorité des priorités donc bon s'ils
sont pas en danger j'aimerais bien
savoir pourquoi est-ce qu'on les a
évacués via Pagan et ensuite concernant
les critères dès lors que le Conseil
d'État a estimé que ces personnes
relevaient de la protection
fonctionnelle et bien on était plus dans
les mêmes critères un petit peu à la
louche de la relocalisation les critères
de la protection fonctionnelle c'est
avoir effectivement travaillé pour
l'État même sous contrat et subir des
menaces du fait de cette collaboration
donc maintenant les critères si vous
voulez ils ont complètement changé
maintenant nous sommes sur des critères
de la protection fonctionnelle et
malheureusement actuellement on est en
contentieux notamment devant le tribunal
administratif de Paris qui nous dit que
et bien il y a pas de preuves de menace
sauf que quand on apporte quand les
clients apportent des lettres de menaces
qu'ils expliquent que leur maison a été
incendie etc et ben nous explique que
c'est pas probant donc
on est un petit peu dans une situation
où quoi que l'on donne ce n'est pas
probant pour montrer que les personnes
peuvent être finalement potentiellement
victimes quand les avocats ont trouvé
cette faille administrative pour afin
d'avoir la protection fonctionnelle pour
pour les PCL l'État a répondu en
essayant de de pointer les dossiers qui
pouvaient avoir certaines failles qui
pouvaient avoir des dossiers qui ont été
falsifiés etc vous le disiez vous
essayez d'avoir le plus de preuves pour
montrer que certains ont été menacés il
y a plusieurs exemples un un pcrl est
encore en Afghanistan un interprète son
enfant de 6 ans a été tué par les
talibans il a reçu un courrier disant
que c'était une première menace une
première formation il n'a pas été évacué
il est encore là-bas parce que la DGSE a
mis dans son dossier ce qu'on appelle
une note blanche vous pourrez peut-être
mieux l'expliquer mais c'est une enquête
qui n'est on n'a pas accès à l'enquête
on a juste accès à la conclusion qui est
de trois phrases et qui dit peut-être
que Monsieur Intel est en relation avec
les talibans vous ne disiez tout à
l'heure dans votre situation
évacuer
est-ce que un jour ou l'autre vous
pensez pouvoir retourner dans votre pays
est-ce que c'est c'est le rêve
aujourd'hui de de ce qu'on a vu dans ce
documentaire de vous compatriotes des
familles est-ce que c'est le rêve bien
sûr aujourd'hui et est-ce que vous avez
des résolutions depuis 7 ans je suis en
France d'un côté je suis content que je
suis en france et je travaille toujours
en tant que l'interprète pour les
immigrants afghans et de l'autre côté je
me sens un peu triste que ma famille et
son en Afghanistan j'ai pas d'occasion
de le rencontrer il faudra un changement
de régime pour que vous puissiez
rentrer j'attends quoi un jour l'état
actuel chute et puis je pourrais rentrer
en afkan essence chez nous et il n'y
aurait pas de possibilité de rentrer en
Afghanistan et s'il y avait une demande
à formuler auprès de l'État français
aujourd'hui ça serait laquelle
ce sera de sauver
la vie de notre famille qui se trouve en
Afghanistan d'où vient de notre
accolaboration avec l'armée française
tout simplement
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur ce
plateau aujourd'hui merci également à
toutes les deux après ce documentaire
que nous venons de voir dans ce débat
doc entièrement consacré donc à
l'accueil de ces fameux auxiliaires qui
ont travaillé auxiliaire civils bien sûr
qui ont travaillé avec les troupes
françaises lorsqu'il s'agissait de mener
la guerre en Afghanistan vos réactions
ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur
Twitter merci à celle massali qui comme
à l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission puis je vous donne tout
simplement rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera bien entendu avec
son documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]